the dog is whimpering the dog it's very
cute it's adorable and I don't mind the
whimpering I'm just concerned for it I'm
not your rich rich I don't think rich
cares much for the dog though I based on
your behavior during the break it really
doesn't seem like they fight for
attention who rich in the dog the dog is
very cute but the dog it's not just the
smartest look how cute the dog is it's
adorable it's not a show dog
yeah it's a go what kind of what kind of
dog is it a Yorkie it's a tiny little
Yorkie
it's very pretty she was under a pound
when we got her but she's not she's not
a puppy Stella she that's as big as
she's gonna get yeah she's tiny yeah
that's great like six pounds but yet
you've never even mentioned having a dog
like I'm here all done I never knew you
had a dog yeah well we never have dog
talk you know I just don't you know we
don't usually carry our dog with us
we're not Liza whatever Liza she brings
her dog everywhere so people you know
dirt she's used to it you know I feel
uncomfortable bringing a dog into studio
because I've never done it before I see
I don't wanna yeah I feel but I don't
want to take advantage of your show here
right bringing a dog in so I feel that's
what I feel uncomfy talk was [ __ ] it
was less than I talking a beverage
[ __ ] two weeks thirsty ass dog yeah
like drinking down a Poland Spring
bottle like this is a look can you take
her off the console I don't know she's
got the thing you're the leash around
her neck we'll stop her from falling you
just revelation she's making her way
around the console right now the dog is
and it looks like yeah she goes to a
relationship with him she wants so many
vehicle intelligence she died she goes
to the one that doesn't doesn't give her
the love all the time you do oh I don't
play with her I just get mad
I just get mad we had to put in new
floors because of her why cuz she pisses
yeah yeah that would dry that's why we
had to train or no I'm
the greatest at punishing yeah so could
you get someone to train you pay
somebody they can do that I don't know
if you know who I'm married to
we do that's a good we do I know you
could pay a dog trainer and then you
wouldn't have to buy new floors is the
thing I think like it like body saying
if you just paid the dog trainer in the
beginning that investment would have
saved you five new floors well I didn't
know that cuz we thought she would learn
you know we thought that just the
instincts it was he would dog would do
something bad and then he which is still
the thing and then he would yell at me
and then that's that's how he likes to
do things he just right so the dog would
notice him disciplining you and then the
dog would get so scared she would have
piss in the house anymore so know when
he's gone she's perfect no she isn't
she's very perfect and then when you
come back you add an energy to the house
that scares her I think that's why she
poops by the closet here's the deal
right I it's like our kid I play with my
kid I love my kid so so you're not the
disciplinarian no you bark at everyone
constant he does right yes young people
I tell Rayna all the time he's his bark
has no bite which is why she doesn't do
what you tell her to do cuz she honestly
does not care about getting yelled at
but was undermining your discipline yeah
that does that doesn't help him for you
for the mom just say like you don't have
to worry about dad like he doesn't did I
say I tell Rayna oh yeah yeah you do and
you the thing is does your daughter not
respect you rich if she does but they
came up
to me oh I see you know she's like a
little she's like if Barney had a hump
on her back it would be my kid she's
just a part of you she's exactly like
you his reign aside with Bonnie are
usually with her no matter what
oh are you kidding me when is she ever
side with me once at every one time you
were right you know whatever you know it
it is what it is on my two older
daughters I you know like me better so
right so you're fine two out of three
ain't bad
no it isn't and one of them came by the
party by the way yeah yeah Jessica came
by the party no Ellen Ellen did did you
have fun at the party rich a genetic
that the Gymboree I was there from two I
was 4 to 10 yeah I had a great time yeah
I do only there was only one thing that
upset me was that the hosts that they
didn't have a smoked chicken head
support they'd wait for the wings yeah
yeah I smoked chicken was an option
pulled chicken smoked pill pulled pork
and all that stuff but I didn't know the
smoked chicken I didn't think of smoked
turkey all right that would have been a
lovely option I mean you give hot dogs
too much yeah right I forgot to even
bring something like every party I go to
I bring something I forgot yeah and I
party gifts they stop and get a bottle
of wine or some flowers or something for
those flowers at a party like rich
riches has no like what do you call when
you can't see education I always say hey
let's bring I say let's bring turkey
burgers cuz I need turkey burgers or
something does rich paint the picture of
the person who would like to be and just
give himself those attributes I think
he's I honestly think he's talking about
me
[Laughter]
it's himself do you think you can fit
he's talking to the person who sees him
every day it's weird but he has an issue
if you wanted to get into it I don't
know we do this morning but he will not
admit to a flaw get him to admit to a
flow she's stupid a lot of the issues
that you guys have is that your wife
Bonnie I am I am I look at my life and I
go I guess I am I'm with a look at it's
all right there in front of me I'm gonna
give you a scenario and you tell me the
option you would go it okay okay so this
is like a scenario that may happen in
the voss the karlon happen or whatever
or babe it's a comparison okay you're
driving from 30 in the 30s on on you
know like 30 and fifths sure okay so you
got to go to to fourth Avenue okay first
of all this is the work comedy club that
we're talking about okay
New York New York Comedy Club on 4th
which how many times you've been there
anything again can I finish
you're right she is interrupted here I
mean she's trying to explain it a little
bit but gonna do it without context go
ahead so you go you're going to meet by
the New York Comedy Club right and I was
actually doing Karen Feehan show
upstairs at the yeah I don't know I'm
thinking of a different place but she
said go between maybe she's on forth
between Bowery and second which is okay
now Bowery is below Houston so it would
be between third and second no it is
Bowery that street is called bowring
below house no no I think you're both
thinking of different things
there's Bowery which is is I think isn't
that this is a battery bar on 3rd its
I'm 100% correct pull up a map somebody
it is Bowery I it's on the corner of
second and fourth that's cool man treat
that it's on the other side is Bowery
but she is right try yourself
hundred percent right okay second half
the Bowery ball right that's what we
said the Bowery like the Bowery where
the drunks would always be i think
that's below house yes you're thinking
of the but some place she didn't say the
about she said he's the street is Bowery
but even when rich said the story just
now it was clear to me that bonnie was
talking about a street and on this one
we're gonna go with Bonnie yeah so rich
will we go with bonnie on this one it's
he's not necessarily saying I was wrong
he's saying I should have said it's
between second and third because Bowery
is third no no Bowery then so he made
the mistake and went the wrong way and
then yelled at me for calling it Bowery
instead of third which is a map but it's
always it's called battery it is called
does brown into third though yeah to say
in fact earlier I said hey third doesn't
go down yet so you might want to this is
how we found out so I said you might
want to go this other way and he was
like started yelling at me about how
they were going I haven't said at one
point you want me to put on my GPS and
he was like yeah wait why don't you have
ways on just for traffic like even if
you know where you're going to do it
because he goes to me look up where why
don't you have ways on your phone issues
ways he won't put it on because I put on
my Google I got it like out smart ways
or something it's so silly ways is for
traffic you know you're going I know I
know where I'm going I'll put ways on
because it direct you away from [ __ ]
traffic yeah that's what it does I
literally time you're gonna get there
it's like there's an information other
than just we're saying ways it like
Kleenex it's like your GPS I hate using
GPS but I put ways on every single
morning to drive to work just in case
there's some kind of accident and I have
to take a different way because ways
tells you traffic
thanks for explaining what Jim just said
[Laughter]
no it's okay it's okay it's a tense
situation you know we're trying to
figure out Bowery in third it's the same
street it is you're both saying the same
thing however somos bonnie was way more
right he yelled at me and I yelled and
you are like I got a little upset rich
you presented this scenario as an
instance where bonnie was clearly in the
wrong and what you gave us was an
example of bonnie clearly being in the
right always it's six or one half dozen
the other but it's not what you said you
said she was wrong would you say you if
you were going between third and second
but it could be called Bowery is called
Barry they would depend on the area of
the city I was in if the road is called
Bowery I would say Bowery if it we were
a little further right and in fact I was
like I started to say third and then I
remembered it was Barry I was like
between third and sorry Bowery inside
you know I have to tell you that now I
understand the kawaii bonnie and this
actually is second point for body and
why she brought up the context of where
you were going because she was talking
about a comedy club which is where you
guys it wasn't a comedy club it's the
downstairs of the comedy club is the
downstairs but you should know the
streets near where the comedy clubs are
because that is where you guys make your
living
no that's not one of my main clubs I'm
sorry the fact that you don't use ways
you deserve every bit of traffic and
agony you suffer good but Danny and he
wouldn't get you have a weird fear of
technology of being overwhelmed by it
because you wouldn't get [ __ ] e-zpass
i Patrese wouldn't either I had to
berate you for a decade to get EZ Pass
is this crazy such a good person there's
no reason to go through the cash-only
lane why don't you use Waze though it's
crazy not you I use GPS in the car sting
car yes
they're terrible then I constantly up I
you sometimes Google Maps blue who maps
is not that good yeah this is the best I
mean other ones are tolerable Waze is
the one that works the best
I would trash Jim if you were wrong he's
correct yeah correct on this one yeah
Google Maps for some reason I just
thought I spins me around I just I hate
it like a racer the wrong way sometimes
like the arrows going down and I'm like
why can't you just put it in direction
of travel you [ __ ] [ __ ] I think
you can I've tried can you Travis is
nodding too I've tried it but every time
it updates do you get a reset it oh yeah
yeah it stinks Google Maps which one
switch direction of travel is how I want
my [ __ ] map going I can't if I'm
going north and the thing show the arrow
shows I'm going that's the way I'm
walking it [ __ ] me up yeah and then
you have to like constantly I constantly
have to be like okay I'm facing north
that's the left that's right see rich
doesn't have to worry about any of this
stuff he stays away from the technology
that way he doesn't get right he can get
upset with you instead of kept saying
where is it between what streets I said
why don't you just use your you're here
I'll just I go I already had my app on
so I said just use this no touch me the
[ __ ] streets he wanted Oh last night
he wanted me to call the hotel if you
want to you can but I'm not wasting my
[ __ ] life calling a hotel it's right
here why don't you turn it on is telling
left here go right into block yeah okay
but like why even ask him just telling
me this is how I don't obviously you're
gonna team up against me and no we all
actually secretly think you're right
yeah we're just doing this to be mean to
you oh it feels a little spiteful what's
going on rich I'm on your side tell me
why we had to call the hotel last night
okay stupid now I'm stupid too
keep us straight on it's just I wanted
to know what two streets it was between
so I knew what no where to make the left
or the right so I can we understand why
you'd ask for directions but the bottom
line is the map would direction which
way the park the easiest way to park you
would just see that when you got to be
fair if you google mapped it you could
just have a view of the streets and just
I know New York so well in the hotel
well don't say don't say yeah you don't
okay right yeah I'm going home I can't
have you google it rich it does give you
an area you see all the streets and you
could make your decision very quickly
for future reference you put the name of
the landmark and it [ __ ] comes up you
don't get it because you're not using it
I know in my head because I know you
don't know it's terrible left turn I
know how you keep everything straight
but rich if you just say so if you use
the GPS you wouldn't have to be shouting
at by it frees up all your mental space
because you don't have to worry about
where to go that it actually makes it
easier because you're watching the map
because I have five blocks Baylor you
don't have to think of what street is
this it'll go left turn what's in the
big picture on a macro level then maybe
your relationship would be slightly less
toxic and when you came in and do a
radio show you guys wouldn't have to
pick the two seats furthest away from
each other in the room to broadcast I've
never seen anything like it
everybody does I mean Joe list and Mark
Norman were way closer to each other
than you guys are and you guys are
married yeah well because
I didn't bring you in you're you're a
guest on your own no I'm neither one to
take the credit for Bonnie Bonnie
whatever
oh yeah yeah no I happen to have the
[ __ ] direct line on Joe list and
Sarah's relationship
apparently he won't bring her into the
studio oh my god
it seems exhausting it's I just said
just please don't come he because he
doesn't really he's a big presence
everywhere he goes and he's I know he'll
fight back on this but he's a diva
so that's trips like this it's like you
can't just sit and relax anywhere he's
got a complaint he's got to do this it's
this is wrong this person has a fat ass
why is this it's like endless what do
you mean I have a big just not in a
complementary way no no he took that a
compliment big presence like not like it
that like they're do they are here or
like that thing where like you know home
but it is true like if you came to that
show of Karen last night of cara's life
locked around me and you locked around
you but it would have been like yes
because you get so upset because they'd
be starstruck I think I think the only
reason he goes to 12-step meetings is
cuz he can hear this when he's walking
through I think he went to that funeral
that time just so that because it was
like somebody from the past or whatever
they he wants to be the big shot at yeah
you work very you've worked very hard in
your career do you like a little
adulation sometimes a little respect
from people while respect right and I
respect and I I don't know about that
yeah I get respect
yeah but you like a little more you like
missile out of this show I respect him
so much and I like you so would they
flock around Ritchie fuser Karen show oh
yeah it's very good at making flattering
people so yes she would buy the other
girls that they're they're burlesque
dancers they wouldn't know who you were
ouch
you were the only comic that there was
another girl there before me but she's
left already
and we were late like they were wrapping
up the show how late were you about an
hour you're an hour late to a show well
we came in from Jersey that doesn't
change the class just leave early
yeah but he like he likes that like rich
likes to I just go and do what I do I in
our dating relationship I mean all the
signs were there why I didn't see them I
don't know oh yeah we went right do you
remember being there and I was doing
some bar show and they didn't ask you to
go on and you were I wasn't mad I was I
was going who don't use people know the
business my kurz and they put you on it
was a horrible place you're the one who
put it up going I can't believe they
didn't ask you to go up I mean I was the
only I go who cares I was out of club in
LA
dirt off the shoulder right yeah water
off a duck's back won't admit any you
say wrongdoing ever this one this wasn't
the way he reacted their union employee
union was an error so I was in LA and I
was bombing and she was on the front in
the beginning that said she was on the
phone so happy calling her friends and
was like calling them I don't think they
had text back then yeah they did
no yeah it wasn't big back then my
memories are zero right because texting
wasn't big he's assuming do you think 15
years ago people were tax yes yeah of
course they were on the phone it wasn't
yeah I mean she's not I don't think in
the middle of your set while you're
performing she's going through her
rolodex and calling her friends on the
phone going you got to hear this and
putting her phone but then I turned to
sit around she got mad because I ended
up doing well because it was that one of
her alternative rooms and she wanted to
see me bomb like that but you're so
condescending when you say one of her
alternative rooms
yeah well that's she brought me that was
a room she did in LA I never did it but
you act like her alternative rooms are
beneath you know I love alternative well
it's not the way you said it no that's
how you heard it oh oh here at negative
oaky I mean I I love doing those type or
okay because you could sit on the stool
and just not even be funny good-looking
yes you trying to flatter a little bit
again you feel bad are you a little bit
or do you think sometimes sometimes it's
literally like I don't know what's
happening to him but it's like just a
spewing of negativity from morning till
night it's just everything's bad wrong
and then if you call him out on it he's
like I am NOT you know it's like he does
like to consider himself a positive
person do you like his rings and his
sneakers don't you think it's nice that
when you look at rich you see he's got
his rings you see he's got nice sneakers
on and you can immediately tell this is
a guy financially who's doing pretty
well based on his physical attributes
based on the based on the things that he
spends his money on clearly I know
immediately financially he's doing
pretty well isn't that a good thing no
first of all that's nothing you know as
you're saying it yeah you know that's
not true
what do you mean who puts when you ask
for eggs and turkey butter eggs eggs
turkey there's the turkey bacon in this
[ __ ] pile of a they get you you said
eggs in turkey bacon they put turkey
bacon in the eggs together can I just
see what I'm saying yeah yeah yeah free
food right somebody brings it to them
still not where he gets free food and I
gotta pay for mine
oh yeah the guests are paying where's
the hot never have you taken it out of
your egg money you're paying for Rich's
breakfast Jim what are you talking about
who's that for the intern comes in he
puts down a cup of Starbucks in front of
rich and he just looks at him because
what are you talking about who's that
for it's not nice it's not nice and I
was chaos in here he's yelling at poor
Wyatt he yelled at him cuz he took off
here's my egg money pay for my [ __ ]
breakfast Jim just found out that the
gas are eating on the house and the Jim
is paying for eggs I'm almost positive
that's why rich comes here no I mean I
will say immediately every time he gets
here immediately he goes are we still
doing breakfast is it too late for
breakfast well you're wrong this morning
you're like they get it free it's a
machine I don't want to be late here
because you you guys say they get it
free at the studio I don't want to be
late he's rich is he a bit of a
skinflint no he please
please do this is when I honestly
started feeling bad for rich like his
brain I don't know how I would cope
myself so he's got this thing where he's
always trying to lose weight but he also
can't say no to free food so it's just
this constant you know like if he's at a
casino and they give him $100 food
voucher he has to use the hundred dollar
food voucher like he he was bringing
food home from Gotham you know how
sometimes a potato chip
oh yeah you guys I know you like him my
snacks I'm sorry I was trying to be nice
was he trying to be nice don't just
bring home some chips he's he's
presenting it as trying to be nice and I
do think there's a like a tiny element
of that but it's also there's free stuff
I must have it I didn't take the [ __ ]
bananas or the brownies so one night
Keller not to order coffee because it's
free upstairs no see we were trying to
get here in a rush because I'm gonna
stop at Starbucks and I go there
Starbucks at the studio so we could get
here on time all right
maybe hey you're right we should just
stop and we'll come in here at 8:00 when
you just stroll in you guys are the dark
doesn't like it when you fight you don't
know the dog wants more free dogs dog
doesn't care if they're hitting
something [ __ ] hatchets eggs and
turkey bacon okay for a dog yeah that's
how I feed Bonnie I what story now
whatever that restaurant was that you
took us to one time on a Monday night oh
yeah we order yes chef price if you have
cash and we didn't know it was a it was
a surprise they said oh by the way
tonight if you pay cash it's half price
well rich can no longer concentrate on
dinner conversation or anything this is
before we even get our food he's like
I'm gonna I'm gonna get something to go
I go when are you gonna eat it because
you're already eating your meal now and
you're leaving tomorrow morning right
yeah he does I'm gonna put it in the
freezer so consider a chicken parm and
put in the freezer I said please rethink
it I go what are you saving yourself
like $11 who cares right no it doesn't
matter let's just enjoy but so rain and
our talking laughing I can see him he's
looking off into the distance he can't
concentrate he's like I must get that
chicken parm it's half price so okay he
calls the waiter over he goes listen
I'm also gonna get the chicken parm and
the waiter goes oh if you get it to go
it's not half and he doesn't even get it
done a rich goes forget it Thank You
embarrassed he can't stop himself I'm
not cheap at all I don't think that
you're cheap I honestly think it's
something else it's it's OCD bizarre
like if there's something in the trash
he has to get it out no like he doesn't
see it as gaining he sees it as losing
if he doesn't take advantage of yes he
doesn't see it as I'm getting a free bag
of chips he sees it as if I don't take
this free bag of chips I'll be losing
you'll think about it all the way home
yeah mega chips
why would you take a bite and then
present your my eggs cold oh the dogs
barking he's never wrong okay I already
gave her some eating turkey bacon
[ __ ] all right so I you embarrass
yourself in front of this waiter first
of all he dad I'm sure he did speak
English a little he spoke enough English
to tell you you know it's not half-price
if you were to go that's right right I
said I brought home from my wife you
wanted to order the chicken parm half
price oh boy to go that's so
embarrassing because like I mean you
know you're doing it to get that happy I
know it's like a bizarre well they're
getting you in there cuz that's why you
told you it wasn't half price but you'll
order to go easily said okay I'll eat it
here taking one bite and go I can't can
I have is to go but you I think his
brain takes so much effort in time to
spend money all the time I don't mind I
love Spencer right listen didn't you
hear say I don't think it's cuz you're
cheap I don't think you think you have a
some kind of weird thing with money and
free food you
lose weight but you you eat ever you'll
take two bills from a comedy club I've
seen you do it yes yes I've seen him
order at the beginning of the night eat
his meal and take one to go
yeah really am i name it name a place
everywhere we've ever worked that's not
true
do you like to take a meal to go
sometimes at a comedy club nationally
just to treat yourself to the whole room
service its value property then you take
a little sandwich or something for snack
in your hotel room because there's
nothing to go there's nothing it's not
unreasonable there's nothing open
there's nothing open it's not reasonable
I'm not none of this is unreasonable
none of this is a major problem but
under no but it'd be cut like like you
you got some chips for your wife that's
a nice thing to do but it's every single
time there's some over Gotham I never
bring chips home last year I saw in fact
that you remind don't remember
I believe you brought the the brownies
no I didn't bananas I was looking for
you I'm sorry but isn't there something
embarrassing he always presents it like
I didn't ask for any [ __ ] chance yes
he turns himself into a martyr I Drive
home you go pick me up potato chips how
much did you do that along occasionally
well some chips do you like [ __ ]
ketchup potato chips yeah Alexander it's
gross yeah are all choices to like be
Canadian you know like yeah so
originally from what country was it
Canada it is I believe it's pronounced
Canada okay it's very similar to what
he's so I'll Drive homes go pick me up
or I'll get home oh did you pick me up
on your short venner I know you didn't
ask him so so this time so this time I
said oh let me surprise her you didn't
see me
I see like let's not go off the [ __ ]
rails on this I'm saying it's not one
thing it's everything all combined
you're constantly while you do and Steve
Martin doing Cleopatra I no idea Patrick
[Laughter]
why are you doing Carlin's five dirty
songs
isn't there something embarrassing
though about trying to like having
diamond rings on all your fingers and
then and then trying to get half-price
chicken parm like it's supposed to be a
status symbol yes somebody who's got
enough money to have their fingers
littered and diamond rich comments
should not mind paying full price for
each one I I just like knowing he's
rushing and swallowing a food food when
I do that and take my rings off I see a
popper yesterday we dropped our daughter
off at Camp she goes to camp every year
at Princeton University and rich of
course was wearing is rich outfit but
very similar to this except for us a
purple sleeveless that was red
Oh a red sleeveless right that's cool
right what are they thinking there's a
guy with this ring mousse in the back
backwards they're taking hey this dude
is dude hi fellow kid the afternoon it's
hot right why am I gonna wear so it's
coming anyway just bend on the leg sound
good thing we got that pop filter you
know what I mean so isn't that the
microphone that Ron uses when his
bennington just so you know just so it's
on the table if there's AG on the pop
filter Ron somebody call up Addington
and let him know that was rich for us
and by the way that's not I mean it's
not good it's an audio medium you're
brushing if it'll happen in lighting or
that plant
it's to it in here if you do that people
hear it it's only been doing radio for
35 years
yeah she's wiping tank off a live bike
home today
good let's go to carrion Dallas has a
little bit of insight Kerry yes hey so
today is my husband's birthday and he
has already rattled off five different
restaurants but he is planning on
getting free food from today how old is
your husband or okay that's a lot I mean
it's a lot at that point in life to put
that much energy Thank You Kerry
the thing is to put that like your your
time and your mental energy is worth
something to put that much energy into
getting free it's not free price Mondays
and Tuesdays Alfonso's but like to not
be interacting with your wife and
daughter at the table will not admit he
won't admit to try to get her to admit
to anything I was asking him like is
your comedy great yes is there room for
improvement then he goes there's always
room for improvement I go so your comedy
could be better
it's like he's painted into a corner he
wouldn't admit it do you think your
comedy could be better of course anybody
what could you do better as a comic yeah
what are some could you do better as a
comedian uh the toughy well no no I
could write I'd say I'm not one that
sits down and write to come my stuff
comes to me okay this is gonna turn into
a cop it already has because you say it
comes to him naturally
but to me I could I want to be more
personal onstage as personal as I can
yeah you don't have to call it at a
table they don't book anything I
by trying to talk he was walking around
the studio as a very unflattering joke
this woman is your wife it's not cool
it's not cool at all that just makes it
all worth really rude thing to say about
any woman but you're wiser quick vicious
aside Jim what what could you what are
some of your flaws is a comic these kind
of Sam thing he was saying I should be
more structure when I write I know what
he means about cutting the ideas coming
to you on stage it's not I'm such a
genius to come through it's I've gotten
lazy and I don't write stuff down as
much you just said it totally different
from rich you just said it in a way that
you're actually pointing out flaws rich
didn't say anything he didn't say the
word lazy you didn't say any structure I
said I could do things different I
didn't say I was lazy
it doesn't make it's not better that's
different no it doesn't make you lazy it
makes you everybody's different when it
comes to me all right no everybody's
different when it comes to creating some
calm she could sit and write all day
right that's what she does I'm not
that's not what I journalist for like
tough crowd we we had a write on a daily
basis but do you see the difference in
the way that within five seconds Jim and
you just described the same things and
Jim pointed out actual flaws radio every
day he's good better on the mic no I am
I wish I was better I see Colin with his
note yeah I like Colin who the [ __ ]
might not right it's not it's not that I
don't want to I just think I'll just
talk about it and see where it goes do
you see what I'm saying right yeah just
pointing out flaws yeah too negative and
rich was just like no it's just
different better or worse don't try to
agitate some Dennis not that magic tape
whatever the [ __ ] waters agitate did
you say that word wrong
[Music]
it's amazing that's in peace
it's like Fonzie what that's incredible
I love the dog dogs barking what do you
want right it has been very negative you
know what I like about rich he always
puts funny first it's not about it sure
interpersonal anything it's not about
ever about people's feelings certainly
it's just always about putting what is
funny first Tomic I admire that have you
ever said anything negative about
another comic not publicly not on radio
nope I don't know why this guy's mad at
me or whatever and then you like well I
guess on radio I called him a douche bag
whatever you think and then be like I it
was a funny joke it was a joke
what about Kevin Pollak Kevin Pollak's a
comic you said that's where you're wrong
okay he's not a comic he's a great actor
comedian okay hold on let me turn around
and fix my hair and do [ __ ] Columbo
no he's a great actor right and I didn't
start ever with him he started with me
just like you know he said you know he's
dead so I was only defending myself okay
and and that's it so you have to defend
yourself you will well if someone's
coming in and saying it's a bad thing if
somebody who's not a comic is coming
after me about calm or talking about my
might you know one of my handicaps you
know my little impediment sensitive
about that handicap little Oh No
do you have an impediment yeah she's
talking now
why whoa
Hariyama why would you ask me that like
I don't where you god yes is that a flaw
no it's not a flaw how I I was born so
well you can be born with the flaw
God makes no mistakes Jim yeah God don't
make no junk so I don't know she wants
more eggs she's bothering me about him I
don't have any eggs see we're gonna get
kicked out of studio again again yeah
lardo when you guys kicked out when why
did you guys kicked out of Florida
what he studio was we did monsters in
the morning years ago she walks in and
go who's the head monster it's very
condescending yeah yeah I'm gonna turn
with this
[Laughter]
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app
[Music]